foreign
let's go to Ria in Alberta Canada what's
up Ria
good morning thank you for having me on
Dr John of course how are you you sound
so loud thank you
so um my issue is weight
um I gotta give you a little background
I have been uh Dave Ramsey uh follower
since 2007. I saw him at an event in
2007 in Salt Lake City and I kind of
have been on the program ever since one
time I had a fall off but I got back on
uh Hey way to go sir have you paid you
don't owe anybody any money
done wow here we go
yeah house paid off got Investments you
don't have a house payment
no house payment no house payment no no
um credit card nothing hey do people
listen to the show there's there's a big
chunk of our listeners that don't know
don't don't know what like the Dave
Ramsey program
tell them what it feels like to not have
a house payment and if you got inflation
you got Christmas coming up I know
like oh it's gas is more expensive it's
annoying it's not a choice between gas
or or food right
yeah yeah it is and and you know what
sometimes I mean this Christmas is going
to be a little tight but it you know
um so I'm 75 I've got five kids 14
grandkids
but
um they all know the grandma is not
going to be a cash cow this this year
and I just couldn't live with live
within my means that means you you've
also over the years of paying all your
debts off you've also learned how to
have hard conversation not hard
conversation but just direct
conversations right
that's so great you're incredible Ria so
how can I help you you mentioned wait
how can I help you yeah so you know
since I was about 12 went into puberty I
grew up on a farm I was the oldest one
in the family so I helped with Farm
chores I was always kind of a stuck to
your build like you know not real Slim
Trim 100 pound my my frame is not okay
small and so I always grew up kind of
with low self-esteem I mean I was 127
pounds for all of high school where all
the other girls were 115. like that you
know
um so I think
my grandmas were not hold on hold on
hold on did were people ugly to you or
was this something in your mind were
people mean to you
no I think maybe it was in my mind okay
and I say in your mind like you're not
crazy or anything like that but no no uh
the difference between 115 and 127
I know is not a great it's not a
significant Gap right no
um so maybe to a 14 year old oh make no
mistake about that right so I'm I'm not
trying to minimize it what I'm trying to
I'm trying to get at is was this
something you sensed in yourself or were
people making fun of you were they
laughing at you was your mom always
making comments was your mom always on a
diet and your dad making comments about
her and you you you absorbed some of
that that's what I'm getting at yeah
yeah my mom was always on a diet
absolutely I don't think my dad ever
made a comment and I don't think so okay
but your mom was always talking about
weight and was always on a diet and yes
partition a pear tree okay okay yeah
yeah so you're 75 you've had a a a
remarkable life you've got grandkids
your own kids
and here we are yeah and you know I'm
really I mean I've had some hard stuff
um my oldest daughter passed away when
she was 15 from cancer it was not
diagnosed properly and she passed away
my husband died in a car accident
um you know um I did go for counseling
after
after
you know a number of deaths in the
family I did go for counseling a couple
of different times but it was more grief
counseling and it was it was astounding
how much good that did oh good
um I tried to go back with the same well
it was two different councils actually
did two different times I tried to go
back and talk with them about the weight
because I still think I have that
self-esteem issue in fact I know I do
okay
um but what I'm lying they are so busy
that an issue of what I'd like to lose
is about 30 pounds maybe a little bit
more okay but it's just enough to make
me fluffy instead of streamlined and I
want to be streamlined because that's I
will feel better about Ria okay
so so I had a gastroplasty and it
partially helped yep okay how much did
you lose after that
okay and have you maintained it
no okay so it came back it came back
plus or to come back about about level
um about level no no no no I was 240 I'm
180. and I'd like to get down to about
150. okay so you're still down
significantly
oh yeah absolutely okay all right
okay so there's a lot to unpack here and
I'm gonna try to do it in as dig like as
I said I was gonna say bite size and
then I was gonna say digestible and I
don't want to make food references they
were just from what was coming out okay
um I'm gonna try to make this
um
as simple as possible is that cool
perfect thank you
um I could talk nerd all day we could
call some ex like we could talk nerd all
day let's get to the meat and potatoes
here and again there's yet another food
reference sorry about that so
um
there's a an extraordinary man who is
also a great actor his name is Ethan
suply
and he has
um documented a just an astounding
weight loss and not only weight loss but
just a personal transformation
and my friend uh Dr Lane Norton who's
one of the most one of the
um
Premier voices in the world on nutrition
and weight loss and building muscle and
taking care of your body
um he told me
that Ethan one time said this
when the house is on fire
that's not the time to try to figure out
why the house is burning
like where did the fire start why did it
start when the house is on fire we just
need to get out
let's just get out of the house
and then when the fires burned itself
out then we send in the the arson
investigators the engineers the whoever
to go in and then to do to figure it out
so that it doesn't happen again right
yep so similarly
you can and you've done the work you've
thought through this a lot about where
did this idea that Ria is less than
where did that start yeah and you've
you've pinpointed it as a 12 year old
little girl working on a farm that you
were a little bit bigger than the other
girls in your class and that may just
outside feel outside of the bounds a
little bit my guess is it's deeper than
that
and also my guess is
at this point at 75 doesn't matter
okay let's do the things that we know
are going to help
and I I'm going to tell you all that
with one giant caveat okay and this is a
hard caveat
if you lost 30 pounds in the next 30
days
you know who would be there
Maria
true
and if you lost 50 pounds Maria goes
with you too
and so I want to promise you
that you'll feel that you'll see that
number on the scale and you'll feel so
proud and good for a minute
and then you'll look at Maria
and until you make peace and love her
regardless of what that scale says
you're going to be Chasing Ghosts
okay okay
the Ria I've got to talk to today
is incredible
you've been through hell and back a
bunch of times you grew up at Canada for
God's sake I grew up in Texas and they
told us at church hell was hot
I don't believe that I think it's cold
and Canada sounds a lot right it's
you've been through so much
and you can sit back and look at your
family
and you're going to have a house full of
knuckle-headed little grandkids in a
couple of couple of weeks
yeah you've been a part of changing your
family tree and changing your family
Legacy
and as an outsider I see a lot of
reasons to love Ria
she's an oppressive woman
okay
so the first thing I want you to do
before we do anything else
we get off the phone over the next
couple of days
I want you to write a letter to that 12
year old little Ria
and I want you to tell Ria
what you think of her
and I'm going to ask you to be really
kind to that 12 year old little girl
because you wouldn't talk to her the
same way you talked to grown-up Rio
would you
nope
that little 127 pound 12 year old girl
was beautiful was a hard worker and was
probably hilarious and probably had to
deal with some of her mom's
demons too right yes
yes and that 12 year old little girl you
know what she deserves to look in the
mirror and just smile from ear to ear
and be absolutely in love with herself
because she's beautiful and she's fun
and she's silly and she's goofy and she
doesn't need to absorb mom's weight
issues and mom's personal struggles and
Mom's trauma that she endured as a young
girl and all that
but here we are so I want you to write
12 year old Ria a letter
tell her that you love her
until you're proud of her Let Her Off
The Hook okay
yes all right so that's step number one
step number two is we're gonna focus on
we're gonna practice in this upcoming
new year
on a new identity
you are not Ria the overweight lady
you are gonna be Ria the woman who's a
good Steward of her body
okay ah let's pretend you got 25 years
left
I'm a good Steward of my body I'm gonna
take care of it that means I'm gonna
move
I'm gonna exercise some I'm gonna I want
to be able to and I'm 85.
to kick my grandkids little booty all
over the living room floor when we
wrestle that's what we're aiming for
okay so we are going to become a good
Steward of our body that's our identity
not we're fat and we have to get smaller
so that we can finally love who we are
that's not gonna work
we're going to become a steward of our
body and if we are a good Steward of our
body our weight will take care of itself
okay
yeah so I want you to spend some time
over the next couple weeks before the
new year rolls over asking yourself
what's going to make me a good Steward
of my body
and let me tell you uh we're gonna get
through some of the details down here
but this is important
this last weekend my church had a
potluck I love potlucks
y'all have those in Canada
absolutely oh man in my favorite part of
the church potluck
is the card table full of desserts
and because I've been I've got a great
friend in Dr Lane Norton who has been
really direct with me and been a real
blessing to me
you know what I did
I went in at lunch and I had my lunch
and I annihilated that dessert table
I I at one point I sat down and my wife
looked at me and her eyes got big and I
said I'm making poor choices and I know
and she said okay just wanted to make
sure you were conscious and and at
dinner
I had a small omelet because like a
budget I'd spent my money at lunch
I didn't save it for dinner and you know
what the next day I was down 1.2 pounds
oh okay so I want to tell you that
sometimes being a good Steward of your
body is just having a great day
okay it's not always torture and it's
not restriction all the time and it's
not hatred as my my friend Sal over at
mine pump said you can't hate your body
into making it looking better
that's not sustainable
it's like hating your husband into
loving you more that just doesn't work
okay yeah
so
we're going to start with a new identity
we're going to be a good Steward of our
bodies for as long as we've got it left
okay here's the second thing awareness
and intentionality
there's a gap between stimulus and
response between all of a sudden I miss
my husband
or when your daughter's birthday rolls
around and you miss her
or one of your grandkids calls and says
granny I got a C instead of an a
and your default sitting might be to
grab
a cookie or to go to the store or to get
a large Coke and pour the hole right
is that's an absolute default okay so
here's what we're doing we're just gonna
look for the some space just a gap
between that initial feeling and I'm
reaching for it last night as and I'm
learning this I'm practicing this right
along with you okay I'm no I'm not obese
I'm not struggling but I am trying to
get control of my intentionality
yesterday I was on the phone having a
conversation on the way out the door I
grabbed off my boss's desk he's got a
bowl of candy I grabbed a box of Milk
Duds
and I started walking out and just
before I opened them
I had that space and I set him down on
his admin's desk so I carried them for
about 15 feet
and it was just a gap between stimulus
and response between I'm having a hard
conversation uh I picked these up I
don't want these I'm gonna set these
down okay that's what we're looking for
just a Gap a big part of that is
tracking okay and so here's a cool thing
my friend Dr Lane Norton has what I
think has been a blessing to me my
friends are on all using it now
um
it's the single best
tracking app for what we eat in the
world it's called carbon c-a-r-b-o-n
and he is going to gift you a lifetime
membership you can have it forever
okay
so I want you to hang on the line it was
think Dr Norton it's it's been a
blessing to me and I called them last
night and said hey would you be willing
to gift this it's been such a blessing
to me to to this caller I've got
tomorrow and he said absolutely
um and so you'll stay on the line we'll
get your contact info and it's just an
app that you log into and it tracks your
protein and your calories it just it
helps you be intentional about what
you've eaten over the course of a day
and I thought I was eating about a
thousand calories less than I actually
was
and so there's been a few weeks a few
months where I've had to learn like I'm
not starving I'm not hungry
I'm just used to this space being filled
up with Gummy candies and Milk Duds all
right yes yes and I just have to feel
what that feels like ah feels good
or it feels not great but I'll be all
right see what I'm saying
yes it's the single best
uh weight loss app not even weightless
app it's a coaching app and it's
incredible but I'm gonna give it to you
okay you put on your smartphone and you
can just carry around with you and it's
going to be something that you practice
with okay and
um you're gonna have to come up with
here's number three some sort of
restriction that you can live with
some do vegans some do keto some do what
I don't care what it is but at some
point you're gonna have to say I'm
through I spent my money for today and
money is just calories right I've spent
them for the day and so um I had a
humongous breakfast full of pancakes and
bacon and cool
um I'm gonna have a really light light
dinner I'm gonna go for a walk right
because I spent my money today it's just
like a budget except it's calories okay
um and then the final one is a part of
our stewardship of our bodies we're
going to we're going to move whether
that's exercise whether that's going to
the local YMCA whether that's getting in
one of those swim those like water
aerobics Group whatever that is I'm just
gonna commit to movement it might be
walking around my yard
okay yeah I love to I love to walk when
there's no ice yeah yeah I just gave me
a bike no my kids gave me a recumbent
bike for Christmas right so I've got no
excuse there you go hey watch your
favorite show
there we go put it on there which it was
which Dr deloni right
that's going to make you pedal really
slow it's kind of up you put you to
sleep all right here's the last last
thing I'm Gonna Let You Go okay
okay the last thing is I want you to
write 75 year old Rio letter
and I want you to tell 75 year old Ria
how proud of her you are
how much you love her
I want you to be hug that woman for the
hard stuff she's been through hug that
woman for the great stuff she's for the
hard choices she said to make over the
years for the
her ability to pay off all her debts and
have hard conversations with her kids I
want you to
write 75 year old real letter a reminder
that she's not a failure her whole life
hasn't been a shame she hasn't screwed
up everything
she's a really cool lady
thank you is that cool
yes it is all right I am I cannot be
more grateful for you thank you for
calling for sharing your journey with us
thank you for
being brave
thank you for letting that 12 year old
little girl go play for the first time
in a long time and thank you for loving
my friend 75 year old Ria and big shout
out to Dr Lane Norton and his team like
the incredible carbon app go check it
out where you get apps it's worth it if
you're thinking about losing weight in
the upcoming year or you want to start
lifting weights more whatever your goals
are check it out carbon um and I by the
way I have no Financial affiliation in
this thing at all none zero I make zero
dollars off of this thing I just use it
personally and I believe in it
um in in a deep and profound way
um Ria you're awesome